okay it's an honor to be with you guys
here today I'll try to cover a bunch of
stuff kind of quickly and then we can
get to Q&A which a lot of times I think
is the most thought-provoking for for
everyone first I will say that we've
that the divita village has welcomed 20
of your peers from the prior five six
years into our ranks which is slightly
ahead of my business school alma mater
Harvard but I think we have about
sixteen or so and so we're infused with
the wonderful talent and training that
this place place gives you what what I
decided when I came to this this company
in 1999 was that for this next phase of
my life I wanted to really test the
notion that companies can be a
formidable force for good in the world
while not sacrificing or ignoring their
capitalistic responsibilities or
fiduciary responsibilities to their
shareholders so that was the that was
the basic premise I think you guys may
not face this but my generation I'm 55 I
don't know how much younger garthe might
be than me or or others say you come
speak then in our generation of business
schools that implicit it was it was so
pervasive a philosophy that it was
implicit as opposed to explicit was kind
of the atom's what I call the amis myth
notion of of capitalism which is that if
you if you run a company or you're an
executive in a company your job is to
maximize profit within certain ethical
boundaries that's your job and if you do
that then sir the invisible hand ends up
having that work out pretty well for
society and that was sort of the role
definition and then I think many in your
generation have the more enlightened
view that in fact the notion of defining
business leadership is sort of a moral
where it's about not breaking the law
and behaving ethically but not with a
broader moral consciousness is in fact
philosophically wrong and unsustainable
and then instead of looking at decisions
like where you should place a factory or
what you should pay your the people that
work for you or what that environment
should feel like the folks instead of
looking at that as sort of an amoral
business decision that in fact those are
highly moral decisions and that
companies had this incredible
infrastructure administrative Lee and
culturally in terms of communication and
understanding of each other that
corporations can mobilize and do more
good in the community while trying to
hit their areas per share targets
in in a month and most not-for-profits
can do in two years and to somehow a
society that benefit from some sort of
conscious intellectual and energetic
mobilisation of that is is a crime so so
with that notion we launched our little
a little davido adventure we do call
ourselves a village we say we're a
community first and a company second a
community that just happens to be
organized in the form of a company this
does not mean we don't care about profit
in fact our stocks moved from about a
buck fifty to seventy four dollars over
the last eleven years so we're in the
top 1% of S&P 500 companies over that
period so we we have a lot of regard for
our fiduciary responsibilities but
that's that's that's that's the means
not the end is the basic notion so just
as if you're the mayor of Denver where
we are headquartered you care about jobs
okay but you don't care about jobs into
themselves should care about jobs
because that leads to a healthy economy
which leads to good schools and good
parks and good roads and the ability to
stay competitive in the intense world so
jobs are the the means at the end
similarly what we say is that profits
are fine if you look at them like tax to
the government all right it's okay to
pay taxes to the government if the
government is providing competent
services transparency fairness things
like that then taxes are okay people get
that society has to work similarly
profits to shareholders are okay as long
as they're associated with fairness
transparency a fair deal things like
that so I'm gonna pull away from all
that for a moment in and and throw out
ten ten thoughts on leadership that we
have taken to heart over the years as we
try to infuse every aspect of what we do
in the divita village with this notion
that we can be a force for good first of
all in the lives of our teammates or
citizens now we'll hit forty thousand I
think Tuesday of next week we'll hit our
forty thousand teammate or citizen we
force for good in their lives first and
then second in our communities in the
broader world and so these are ten
thoughts that we've taken away and then
we can kick whatever around you'd like
to some of these again I sensitive to in
this setting because you're such a
thoughtful group in such a thoughtful
institution that that some of them are
probably far more thought-provoking when
I'm talking to room
with fifty five-year-old CEOs then they
might be for you but but we'll play that
out thought number one is is a phrase
perhaps some of you have heard it this
is not a dress rehearsal this is your
life I got a lot of my friends who are
just my daughter's here I didn't didn't
know this I said I know that
I know that way so now I have to tell
the truth
this is not a dress rehearsal this is
your life and I got a lot of friends who
are 55 successful wealthy and not very
fulfilled and they're in a really tough
spot as to figure out how to spend the
balance of their life I got a lot of
folks like that and what it tends to be
is that they've kind of lost track of
what their life was and whose life it
was and what their real what their real
goals were which which leads me to
thought number two and it's from a very
very famous esteemed philosopher called
John Cougar Mellencamp and he said the
most important thing in life is to
figure out the most important things in
your life now say this to a group of
executives you get a lot of people
saying you know what a dumb self-evident
thing to say you know cuz I know it's
most important my life so I love this
when I get to deal with small groups I
said well write it down for me would you
I mean I know it's dumb and self-evident
but write it write it down and enough
specificity so someone could sort of
evaluate it and and and first of all
people have a lot harder time writing it
down than they thought with any sort of
reasonable specificity beyond just
saying you family and whatever and drink
Kirt phrases and I said okay now I just
like to spend a little bit of time going
over here last couple of years where you
spent your money where you spent your
time where you spent your emotional
energy what are the tail effects of all
those things that you've done the last
couple of years and I just want to
compare all those allocations and those
decisions and that energy to what you
said was most important and what you
find is a very a non-trivial percentage
the 42 to 58 year olds in the room don't
feel very good about that
match and it's just been a long time
since they forced themselves to do it
with written rigor versus just when
they're toasting someone at a wedding or
or maybe stopping in a stoplight or
something and and how ridiculous is it
not to bring the same sort of analytical
intellectual and written rigor to
reviewing what's most important your
life and how your actions and decisions
map map with that that you don't bring
that kind of rigor to it that you do to
all sorts of other decisions in your
life it does it doesn't make doesn't
make much sense in in our minds so we
try to bring rigor to that the third is
beauty is in the eye of the beholder
leadership is in the eyes of the lead it
does not matter one bit
not one bit what kind of leader you
think you are you are the type of leader
other people experience you to be period
that is a type of leader you are you can
believe that people misunderstand you
that's fine but you are the leader other
people experience you to be and I'll
tell you get to the point where you can
sit in front of a group of people and
say what they think your weaknesses are
what your behavioral deficiencies are
what your values are well you can say
out loud what they are thinking what
they say to their friend when they're
having a beer with them about you in the
same words that they use until you get
to that point where you can talk about
it with that kind of knowledge openness
and personal comfort then you're not
ready to be a full leader the I actually
well tell it to my daughter story and I
wonder if you even remember this Crissy
the so what I've done periodically is I
get a 360 every year and my request is
so that an outside consultant comes in
and and talks to everybody works closely
with me about my performance in my
behaviors and it includes getting an
explicit score on each of our core
values with comments and I can't change
a score it goes to the Board of
Directors and it's shared with the top
3,000 people in our in our village so if
I'm not walking the talk I'm held
publicly to account and in periodically
I've taken my 360 home I just actually
distribute my most recent one to my kids
and to my wife and to my mother about a
week and a half ago but I've done this
periodically over the last 12 years and
you may not remember this Christy but
she was about 12 13 I brought it at home
and she read it with the capacity that
she could at that age and and I came to
dinner I said Christy what you thinking
she goes she goes well daddy the you
tell me that if you try your hardest
that's that's what really comes that's
what you tell me but the people say that
when they try their hardest but
disappoint you a lot of times you get
angry with them and you make them feel
bad now how do I
yeah and where she went with that I I i
sat there but you know like not knowing
what to say to my daughter looking at me
with their beautiful eyes and all I guys
I said I said what Chrissy
daddy just hasn't grown up enough yet in
that way and she's just puzzled yeah
because she said well you're certainly
old enough you're supposed to you're
supposed to be grown up by now and I
heard you understand their CEO and why
they hug would they took someone not
growing up to be CEO and you see a
supposedly successful accordant Minds my
vague sense is that you at least regard
yourself as successful and and and so
that was good but but what also it led
to in that particular case isn't for a
while not that long but for a while was
actually easier to discuss her report
card because she knew daddy didn't get
all A's and so it was okay to start to
talk more openly about some of that
stuff but anyway to know what people are
thinking about you how they experienced
you as a leader is one of the first
tests of whether or not in fact you were
a leader as opposed to just a manager a
fourth miscellaneous thought is people
don't care how much you know until they
know how much you care this one lots of
Stanford and Harvard MBAs you need to
hear now I'd said when we bring in our
fresh crew every year and they say
what's your single most important piece
of advice this is almost in my top one
or two because what tends to happen with
you you people you're so smart you're so
talented lots you have a lot of ambition
and you get out there and you're very
intent on proving very quickly so that
everyone knows just how capable of
adding value you are system of your
formidable arsenal of intellectual and
management skills and all that you want
to unleash it so that people know when
in fact most of the people that are
working with you or for you know very
quickly that you have that Arsenal and
that's not what they're wondering about
they're wondering if you care about them
they're wondering if you respect them
they're wondering if you're a true team
player or a fake team player that's what
they're one dude that's the question in
their brain not house money or they
already know enough about you just
because you went here and then you
eliminate any doubts about you haven't
been an admission mistake and the first
two months of the job that's not the
question
but so often that's what folks like you
are trying to prove in that first in
that first bit of time thought number
five management is a business skill if
you want to learn more about Management
go to business school study management
study business leadership is a human
skill you want to learn more about
leadership learn more about human beings
starting with yourself a lot of people
write books about leadership and here's
that here's the techniques here's the
practices here's what leaders do and
much more about leadership is about who
you are not what you do and who you are
what your intentions are etc can mean
that widely varied sets of practices
techniques etc can be deemed a totally
acceptable motivational useful helpful
inspirational to folks who work with you
it's much more about about who you are
as a human of course it doesn't suspend
the need for certain native skills
number six of ten leadership is not a
function of position leadership is a
function of behavior so do not fall into
the trap of well I can't really be a
leader until they promote me to vice
president I can't really be a leader
until I become partner once some CEO oh
I'm gonna do what's that run sales then
I can lead right now I'm living in a
world that's fettered by all the
imperfections of the people I work for
and the people they work for and yeah
those are real constraints that affect
what you can do but they don't affect
whether or not you lead well what do
leaders do I say this and at first it
sounds again so dumb and self-evident
leaders lead that mean it's not
situational you don't wait for the right
time you don't wait for the right title
leading is a way of life it's not it's
not a temporary tactic it's not a tool
it's not a practice so leadership is a
function of how you behave there are
constraints on the impact you can have
no one is suggesting you commit career
suicide but leaders don't wait for the
right time they decide that's not a
leadership ability it's a it's a
political preference leaders lead and
it's not based on position no
miscellaneous thought number seven you
may have picked up on this but not
reflected on directly you ever noticed
that no one washes a rental
they see very very rude because they
don't own it that and what so many
leaders don't know is whether you have
10 people working for you or with you or
40,000 how well do you know to what
extent they co-owned in the car what
extent is it just a job where they could
put in a reasonable day's work for a
reasonable day's pay more or less in
both case or is it something more than
that is there some element of implied
social contract or explicit social
contract do they in fact care about the
health of the organization both in terms
of how people behave and the business
success or not is it a much more
transactional utilitarian mutually
morally barren emotionally sterile
relationship so how well do you know if
the people actually do Co own the car
that you're that you're driving a lot of
people have have no real clue and
without calling the question without
asking the question without letting the
people speak about their degree of
ownership or lack thereof you are never
going to get to the point where you have
it just like with your own behavioral
deficiencies if you don't get to the
point where your people are talking
about whether or not the organization
lives its core values where the people
talk about their sense of philosophical
emotional spiritual team ownership or
not where they are talking out loud with
honesty positively or negatively then
you are not in the path to creating
organization that adds
distinctive sustainable value added to
people's life outside of the paycheck
outside of the paycheck we believe so
much that if we help people grow if we
help people feel more fulfilled at work
they will be better mommies daddies
siblings kids citizens of their
community citizens of the world but if
we drain them of energy with how we work
with them if that relationship was
excessively utilitarian than their
ability to give to the world and give to
their family it dramatically reduced by
what we've done miscellaneous thought
number 9 that goes 9 to 12 that's her
the a community produces most what it
honors most and this one's very
important at the Vita we reward business
accomplishment
big we give big equity words we give big
bonuses so we we love those people who
put a lot of capitalistic points from
the on the board and we reward them but
we don't honor that behavior we honor
human behavior so we do things like with
core value Awards at throughout the
organization well just give an example
to senior level every January I'll send
out a message to the top 140 liters and
so it's time for the annual core value
nominating process so we take it very
soon this year we got about eighty seven
nominations and that's Vice presence
above nominating other people we often
share the nominations
so if Tammy writes one for Fred I might
send it out to everybody so everyone
sees that Fred got nominated for the
core value of integrity or the core
value of team with examples so Fred's
honored even if he didn't win Tammy's
honored because a thoughtful nomination
is seen by the rest of the people say
whoa Tammy took the time to write that
in a very thoughtful way very
substantive way we do that for about
eight weeks we'll be halfway through a
dinner and I'll suddenly I stopped the
business discussion hand out a sheet
that has 140 names and there's seven
core values and say okay the rest of the
dinner is all about nominating you can
nominate someone at the dinner you can
nominate someone odd to dinner but let's
talk about it that's always amazes me if
you talk to a CEO and you go okay
revenue is revenue important and the CEO
looks at me like I'm brain dead missus
yeah revenues important to Katy it's
okay and you have meetings and reports
and they go yeah there's a really stupid
questions of course we have meetings
reports and brainstorming sessions about
how to protect revenue and Grabbe like
okay good
I got it's important so you have
meetings and process and creativity and
brainstorming so how about expenses you
got you know same thing yeah this is
alright now how about how about your
core values so what's know what kind of
meetings do you have talking about that
what kind of metrics do you have what
kind of initiatives do you have to
improve people's individual and
collective behaviors versus the core
values well you know that's more
intangible we don't we don't kind of do
that that's a little uncomfortable
talking about and we say my guy said
that'd be as dumb as saying I don't
maybe as dumb as saying I love to tell
my wife and kids I love them because
it's assumed as they say not a good idea
not a good idea certain things need to
be talked about
especially because in day-to-day life in
a business especially if your boss is a
jerk it's hard to live the core values
because the pressures budgets and aging
parents and other things push those
aspirational day-to-day behaviors out
there's a wonderful Buddhist saying
spiritual practice is what you're doing
right now right so it's not about a
speech it's not about every now and then
a momentous decision that it particulars
a later particulars an organizational
leader spiritual practices how you
behave every little minute of every day
and what kind of impact you're having on
the other human beings and if you don't
talk about it as a group we have a thing
where every single executive it gets the
annual professional development of you
for me the second section evaluates them
on each of our core values in writing in
writing and so and so you have those
moments where I say hey Jon you know
other people experience you is very
average and integrity or this is how the
experience we from a team point of view
or accountability or continuous
improvement these are our core values in
writing because how can you possibly
simultaneously hold the notion that yeah
we take our core values seriously but we
never talk about them and we never
comment on how individuals behaviors
conform to that in a world where there's
all sorts of pressures that can force
you into a real ordinary average
regression to the mean kind of behavior
it's in fact is what a lot of big
companies are and we always say to
people our core values but the only
fortune 400 company where the people
chose the name of the company the people
chose the logo the people chose the core
values all by election let me go on to
number 10 the yeah and that is that
intentionality rules intentionality
rules that people can smell your
intentionality and whether or not that
your relationship with them is basically
a means for advancing your career or
your relationship with them is to some
extent an end in itself that this is not
about charisma this is not about being
articulate that in the end a very high
percentage of human beings can smell
your human intentionality and that will
dictate whether or not they deem you a
leader they're willing to follow or not
yeah whether that someone who cares
about their growth or not and it's one
of the things about leaders is it's a
leaders job not to create followers it's
a leaders job to create other leaders
when you think about growing an
organization and then maybe I do do one
additional one before stopping
a lot of you are gonna go on to pretty
intense careers not-for-profit world
for-profit world government sector NGOs
whatever but it's a Buddhist thing one
cannot pour from an empty cup
you cannot give what you do not have and
so unless you have a way combined with
whatever ambition you have which
sometimes is high
combined with the pressures that you'll
feel because of the positions you're
gonna be offered intake which will be
high combined with that if you don't
have a reasonably intellectually
coherent pragmatic disciplined sense of
what you're gonna do to refill your cup
then it's gonna be hard for you to do
that for others oh you got to refill
your cup physically emotionally mentally
spiritually and however you define that
if you don't do that then your ability
to help other people keep their cups
full will be dramatically limited you
cannot give what you do not have others
cannot give if you don't help them
replenish their cup and so we define our
mission is not just wanting people into
a good job in our dialysis company but
we hope to create an environment a
conversation and a process and a lot of
things we do into Vida University so
that the teammates that work for us
become better mommies and daddies better
cousins better citizens that's that's
our objective when we talk about
building leaders at de vida it's not
about creating business leaders it's
about creating life leaders for whom
business confidence is a subset of that
but not the thing so I will stop there
and now turn it to questions comments no
embarrassing stories from Chrissy you're
not a student here you're not allowed to
speak so I understood from you that
leadership was more about behavior than
skill so I would like to ask you what do
you consider to be your behavioral
shortcomings how did you find out about
them and what are you doing to improve
them yeah thanks a lot and actually I'll
take a question from somebody else the
the for me it's been quite a journey
this last twelve years and and
forgetting I and I started this I was 43
and when I the metaphor I developed in
the first couple years when some of the
same negative stuff was popping up in my
360 every year the metaphor is it's like
being an alcoholic that that when you're
40 and you still have some of these
behavioral deficiencies and you've been
a CEO
while you got to recognize that it isn't
just see someone gives you the feedback
and you have an epiphany and suddenly
stop acting that way just like an
alcoholic for the most part that I could
tell you I just decided to stop and it
was easy and I'm never tempted and so so
for me on the part of the questions and
a number of these items I've literally
had to give myself a daily score then if
I waited for the next year I'd be I'd be
better for two weeks after the 360 and
then I'd slowly regress back to my prior
behavior pattern and then it'd be ten
months before my next week 60 and then
I'd be good for a month and and go back
so I I literally got to the point where
not only did I empower people who sort
of raised their hand when I was doing
the bad naughties but second every every
night I kept the spreadsheet with a
score to try to build my muscle memory
my ability to recognize when I was going
down the bad path so some I've
eliminated over the last seven eight
years and others I haven't the one on
getting angry with people and then I
performed actually the last two 360s
were the first ones where that was a
minor minor point and not totally gone
but a fraction of what it was before but
it took me eight eight years of having
it repeated in the old days another one
was micromanagement the big one that's
still in there was just two weeks ago is
I my ratio of positive to negative
feedback is not right that I'll give too
much negative feedback is relative to
the positive and I think about refilling
cups I'm excessively relentless and I
don't mean that in a in a good way
and so the - two big ones in there today
still are the relentlessness that can
just be draining for people and the
ratio of positive to negative feedback
sure hi thanks for coming when you enter
that WETA you found a company where
morale was very low and people were
feeling frustrated and scared of the
situation how did you get them to
believe in these new culture and buying
into all these changes that you wanted
to execute yeah it was hard so that the
company if a single bank
for a single dollar we would have had to
close our doors we were then six weeks a
missing payroll on at that point 10,000
people investigated by the SEC sued by
shareholders no CEO oh no CFO no CIO no
VP of HR that all you'd have been fired
because of the implosion or quit we
couldn't track our financial outcomes
and couldn't track our clinical outcomes
people pretty pissed off and the no way
what I realized is that is that a crisis
is an opportunity for a leader the it's
the metaphor I use is why do they pay so
much money for Super Bowl commercial
time yes stunningly if whatever it is
three million dollars for a minute the
most in the world it's really simple
they do it for the self-evident reason
that everybody's watching and
everybody's listening for a leader in a
bad spot it's like that and the bad news
is you're in a bad spot the good news is
everybody is watching and listening so
if you can figure out with clarity what
message is you're trying to convey what
do you really believe in people are
going to pick up on it a hundred times
faster than they would otherwise because
of that differential intensity and the
fact that you're doing it when times are
bad so so one was we started talking
about the core values in developing our
own right away and and this was more
intense than you might guess because my
first meeting was in a group about half
this size and said okay we spent a start
to spend a lot of time talking about
core values and a vision for the future
well 2/3 of the room thought that was a
really dumb idea they say first of all
you know we don't trust you you're
you're new and you get that beign stuff
and the last company I ran got taken
over so you're probably just here to fix
this
and and flip this take a bunch of money
out and leave and and even if you're
sincere you're kind of dumb we can't
barely meet payroll let's not start
talking about core values so so a third
of the room was literally insulted that
I would be demeaning them by thinking
that they'd fall for such a little bit
of rhetorical flourish a third said okay
that's kind of the fat of the month for
the quarter and maybe a third were
interested one of the guys who was most
skeptical as is now one of our SVP is
right over there the and so and so we
started
we started talking about it recognizing
when things I say is is it leaders speak
their dreams because if you if you don't
you probably won't ever pursue them and
the metaphor I use is if if there are
eight of us together here and we're near
the mountains if there's if I'm thinking
I'd like to climb the mountain but I'm
afraid I won't make it I'll just say I'm
going to go for a hike and I get halfway
up the mountain I'm cold I'm tired I'm
hungry I say am I glad I didn't tell my
scone at the top because I'll go back
down see I had a great hike if I told
him I was gonna climb the mountain hold
all of other facts constant halfway up
cold tired hungry you're ten times more
likely to go to the top only because you
told people you would human behaviors
are like that if you say out loud to
people but taking a bunch of these
people here are skeptical and I said
really like to have a special place
where thousands of our people across all
these small dialysis centers don't even
have their own phone extension or email
address because they're hands-on
blue-collar caregivers that we want them
to feel differently about their company
feel an unusual level of emotional trust
and mutual social commitment without
sacrificing and then performance and you
know knowing that a whole bunch eople
that group are gonna go
that's probably [ __ ] that's but by
my singing out loud despite knowing that
a bunch of them don't believe it I know
I'm gonna work harder the next day to
make the decisions on the margin to make
it come true and so every eight weeks I
get a call with a couple thousand people
and literally set out loud the following
question what is the incremental
evidence that we are serious incompetent
about our mission and values for getting
all the other business stuff about the
turnaround because because that's the
question
people are asking and if I hadn't know
and I had to ask and answer that damn
question out loud every eight weeks a
whole bunch of times when I would have
gone home at ten o'clock at night
instead of spending an extra hour
thinking about what could we do on top
of everything else to try to move the
ball forward and be a community first
so bunch of little examples in metaphors
but we I talked about it out loud there
were times one night it was a group
again about half the size I went up to
my room and cried after they I talked
because I knew so many people in the
audience but I was either saying things
that were not ivar foolish or insincere
but we talked about it and then what you
find is that some people cross the
bridge in our parlance and they'll come
up and say
Katie I'm I'm there i I want to be a
co-owner of that vision and then it
starts to spread and that's when it gets
to the point where you let other people
speak because in the end it doesn't
matter what I believe or what I think it
only matters what the people think so
talking about it out loud talking about
it and enforcing ourselves to come up
with specific real-world examples of
decisions or actions that reflected a
differential emphasis on our mission of
values for thousands of people and in
small groups and then starting to let
other people speak because in the end
the people decide what kind of place
it's gonna be and they're the only ones
that can make it the way they want it to
be it's our job to facilitate the
conversation and get out of the way
thank you sir what was the culture and
your leadership style like at vivre and
how did that experience impact you and
decisions you made when you move to
divita yeah I got very lucky though the
leader the bosses I had at Bain and then
and then the vive environment I was
regarded as a very good team builder at
ed Bain and at vivre but it was very
different because at that point although
I didn't know it yet the team building
was a means and a better cantle career
higher stock price higher net worth was
the end and it wasn't anything insincere
about the team legitimately happy teams
but it was a much more sort of
philosophically spiritually superficial
thing it was a team created for a
business goal and everybody liked each
other nothing wrong with it it was that
quite quite fun and we would have we
were a football team it would have
bought a bunch of football games but we
weren't dramatically affecting each
other's lives or anything broader than
our business purpose we were just
advancing our careers in a reasonably
team oriented way and and for me the
decision to go to De Vita was a very
torturous family decision
very tough when I should do it and so I
for the first time in my life I had to
give serious life thought to what I
should take and why because it was a
very strong line of thought that I
should take six months off and go into
the not-for-profit world which was the
plan and so I did really stare at that I
want to do this for ego reasons to prove
I could be CEO and turn around a bigger
company make some more money or did I
want to do it because I could do more
good for the world and the answer was
not obvious I mean it's not one of those
things where it's a hundred zero is zero
a hundred so we went through a
hellacious month as a couple thinking
about it and so I entered into the job
with a lot more purpose and what I
realized X months in is that the means
that ends had switched without me
realizing yet that that at divita the
profit has been the means and the
community has been the end which is the
opposite of what I was before and it
turns out there's a very big overlap and
what you do in terms of the
team-building activity stuff like that
but the texture of it is radically
different thank you thank you once you
set the culture in the beta how do you
prevent people from being drained out so
that they either leave or that culture
just becomes that knowledge and it is
not longer practicing the your company
yeah yeah I'd say a couple of things we
we might still have the slide we took
this very seriously so if you're gonna
roll out a product relevance strategy
you do analysis you have a plan you have
milestones you have metrics you talk
about it so both kind of the intangible
elements of a strategy of increasing
innovation or driving international
growth or whatever in the tangible
they're all very rigorous we said what
we want to do across hundreds of small
locations with people we can never even
get in the same room with because they
work different ships and all the rest
different days is we got we have to have
a plan so we had a very rigorous plan
that included a focus on language if we
don't get the language right where
certain words have credibility and means
certain things we're toast I mean it's
it's no different than trying to create
a jingle for a commercial I mean no no
product man is legitimate unless it's
sustainably authentic there's similarly
for a
cultural brand within an entities
there's nothing wrong with talking about
marketing it and thinking about language
it's long it's a authentic and if we
didn't do that and develop our own
sayings like one for all all for one we
were dead with thousands of people who
have never gone to college barely
finished high school that we're never
get to talk to live if we didn't come up
with a language and then a view that
language of credibility we'd be dead so
first of all we thought about language
traditions rituals it says note you
think about any society any tribe any
village they have traditions they have
rituals they have language because it's
essential to passing along the culture
and the norms but companies don't do it
because they don't think of themselves
as communities but there's nothing sort
of stunning about it it's it's it's
self-evident when you think about
communities and then people turn their
brain off when they think about
companies so we did the language and the
rituals and the traditions a second we
put our money where our mouth is and we
do things like every single teammate
across the country every single citizen
divita village is invited to a two-day
Academy for many of our teammates
they've never been in a plane they've
never checked into a hotel with a credit
card and they come two days no applied
training it's about a mission our values
our history I get presented to and
talked to by some of the senior person
in the company we've been putting out
over 30,000 people through this it's
actually getting closer to 40 so number
two is we invested so that it becomes
part of the DNA and then third we have a
whole bunch of those traditions and
rituals are automatically set up to
reinforce you think why do societies
have fourth of July Memorial Day Labor
Day Christmas Rosh Hashanah whatever
they all do that to force people to step
back and think about their lives in
their society in their aspirations and
their kids and their family and their
tribe it's a very natural thing but you
are part of communities of tribes that
do that geographical cultural or
religious so we did this we do the same
thing and so things like those core
value words hundreds of those happen
automatically across our village every
quarter which is just like having a 4th
of July parade only it's in a dialysis
clinic where you're honoring some nurse
for being a core value Award winner of
team so we did the language and and we
do the the reinforcing rituals and
traditions in a very recurring
systematic way on top of the ad hoc
events and then we we put a lot of money
in it and so our divita University
classes have a highly unusual mix of
stuff around self-reflection interest
action life purpose very unusual that
that's our gift of thousands and
thousands of people whether they stay or
go but that does mean is for those who
stay the the DNA divita is very strong
so it's at this point it's locked and
loaded you could take out a whole bunch
of executives but the the corpus has it
in their DNA
thank you thanks for your time
my question is in my own experience I've
struggled with managing performance with
also the need to make sure that the team
is feeling fulfilled can you talk about
how you it doesn't sound like balance
but hobby but kind of achieved both in
your work with divita yeah we feel
strongly that there is zero conflict
between performance standards and
creating fulfilling environment there
and and so first of all you have it but
but we try we create that clarity
because if you don't create that clarity
up front in particular that's we get
2,500 managers to simulate the company
if if we don't give them the words in
the language to have that locked and
loaded it gets very difficult because
when they're talking to a tech patient
care technician and going through the
annual review and it's got the mission
and values box you can't let that get in
the way of the technical performance
it's it's important but it's got to be
separate now we also talked about the
linkage and that stronger mission and
values performance affects how the whole
team does but we believe step number one
is you have to have total clarity that
they are they are independent you can
have a very strong performer from a
technical point of view business point
of view a person who closes a lot of
sales
who's terrible on the mission and values
stuff and for us that's unsustainable
they have to be reformed or go or you
can have the opposite someone's great on
mission and values fulfillment but we
can performance they have to go to
because in a community you can't afford
unless you have enough productive
citizens you can't afford to take care
of the homeless and you can't afford to
reinvest in the schools so it's it's
again we try to make decisions with that
metaphor and just as a community Kant
doesn't want someone who's really
wealthy but doesn't care and doesn't
give any money to the parks and is a
jerk and and
takes advantage of other people in
different ways you can't that's really
destroys the health of the village there
similarly having people who don't
contribute and don't show up for work
doesn't make for a sustainable village
so we use the metaphor we're very clear
intellectually up front and then you
recognize that there's always gonna be
some noise out there and that's
appropriate because the fact is if he
gets someone who's really strong a
mission of values you are willing to cut
a little slack on the performance side
and and vice-versa so so that's what we
go for it strong intellectual clarity
use of the village metaphor and so it's
common sense everybody kind of goes yeah
there's a little tension in the middle
but they're separate thank you on a
couple of occasions you alluded to
Buddhist philosophies and I was
wondering to what extent does faith
permeate into your professional life to
the persona that you project to the
company and in your leadership
philosophy yeah we we never talked about
I never talked about faith at work
because we're incredibly diverse group
of folks and and so I I'm horrified that
I can't go there without somehow
creating noise sort of philosophical
noise what we do talk about is the
spiritual aspect of life separate from
separate from the physical emotional and
mental and we do put that aside and then
that means very different things to very
different people but so far no one no
one wants that to be parsed through by
by faith and we don't ever refer to
anything out of this world we just say
that for many of us there's a spiritual
element to life or there could be and
without putting any further label on it
that seems to that seems to work because
the subject matter that you deal with
your employees must have to contemplate
those issues you know if you have people
on dialysis that have a you know fairly
substantial mortality do you do you
counsel does the company counsel its
employees on how to manage those sort of
issues or is that left up to the
individual
see do we counsel the individual
caregivers about in Africa patients
exactly yeah we do a pretty we do a
pretty mediocre job of that maybe a
mediocre is nice we we probably would an
average job in it compared to our
industry and that's lousy III would say
there's probably the honest answer we've
just gotten good the last few years we
one thing you start running things that
are large and more complicated you kid
to be embarrassed at what you realize
about your own organization so about
four years ago after I'd already been
there eight years we realized we do a
terrible job of managing the death
experience and and 15 percent of our
patients die every year that's
significantly lower than if you're a non
divita at center where it's more about
18 so so we're really good the but 15% a
lot and we while we had good procedures
around it
it was we were not a we did not act like
a community when it came to the dying
thing both for our own teammates and for
the families and so we established a
circle of life program where we've now
do a bunch of things that both our
teammates and our families are finding
hugely beneficial to help them in their
journey towards death and dealing with
it right after and if you're in a clinic
it can be tough you 15% it means you're
gonna have a number of people dying
every single year and of course for the
family it's less often but more even
more traumatic so that's the one area
where we're now good proud but in the
rest of it you know actually Lindsay you
had had can you put that down because I
is one of these things where that was
this kind of sound I haven't really we
haven't faced up to that reality that
outside of that we're still crappy so
thank you hi so one of the things that a
lot of us talk about really enjoying as
part of our GSB experiences that it has
increased our propensity to kind of look
to others to achieve things that were
interested in achieving to that end I'm
really curious to know about who some of
the most impactful thought partners and
mentors were for you as you kind of went
through your business career well first
to
for pre-business two high school
teachers
Robert earth and John Morita both math
teachers who were just stunningly humble
hard-working virtuous citizens and I was
involved in student council in that and
they were incredibly giving and how they
mentored me and I realize now how they
built within me a reservoir of sort of
citizenship orientation and aspirational
stuff that then almost got killed by
subsequent stages of my career but
fortunately it was substantial enough
that I could tap back into the aquifer
much later the and then for me I'd to
leaders at Bain Tom Tierney and John
Donahoe Donahoe this speaks here there
was some regularly the CEO of eBay that
I've worked for tyranny and Donahoe
worked for me and then I got out of his
way so he could take over the firm
rather than push me aside the they were
both very good very very much better
than me at being well-behaved every day
I was much more erratic I'd build a
great team and then I brutalized people
the next month and you know I was going
like this and they were much more steady
state and I really marveled at that and
got to learn a lot and then I had one
client in my vein days a guy named dick
Fontaine who I just latched on to me has
been sort of a shaman for me ever ever
since was just an elderly gentleman very
wise who asked me very important
questions and wouldn't let me get away
with superficial answers and still does
that to this day so those those five
people if I go outside the people like
my wife are the ones that gave me gifts
that I'll always be grateful for because
I without those five again going outside
the family there's I would have done a
lot more damage than I have I thank you
you spent a number of years in
consulting and then have had a long
career in industry and so I'm wondering
as you look back on some of the biggest
lessons you've learned over the course
of your career do you think that being
in a consulting role
prepared you for the biggest challenges
that you were then going to face or do
you think it wasn't until you were sort
of on the ground actually doing these
issues that you were able to sort of
figure out what the right way of dealing
with an issue either from an operational
side or from a leadership perspective
yeah so first of all someone says you
spent a lot of years in consulting and
you've had a long career in the industry
that they're basically saying you're
really old
they paid along this along them but
separate from this length thing the I I
think for a lot of the stuff that I'm
talking about consulting is not good
although some of the firms are wonderful
and I love my time at Payne I've
absolutely loved it and as I told you
two of my seminal mentors were from
there but it's just not the same it's
just not the same as the kind of
accountability you have for human beings
in a different type of organization both
the type of people in there and their
incredible career mobility that they
have and and the ambitions they have and
all that in the dynamic is it's very
different they don't they don't want the
gift that you can provide people who
make $14 an hour and are never gonna
retire early and so so part of it's a
need thing and then in part was just the
nature of the business so having said
that if you're sensitive to this so when
I was there I wanted to work on
implementation cases I wanted to work
for the clients I thought were the best
leaders and so in that sense it was
great because I got to be exposed to
it's like going to business school I got
it well I wasn't doing I was able to
give given I wanted it I got exposed to
lots of people from whom I learned a
huge amount but it was it was because of
my career path at that point as opposed
to something that would be available to
everyone it could be if there was
pursued and and I having said that I
want to go back I for me so the question
is to a lot of this kind of leadership
philosophy stuff that's the answer as to
whether or not my business career is
better off because I did it peg answers
unambiguous yes that there's very
crudely stated there's sort of two
groups of people which of course is
always wrong there's people who are
really smart and
gonna not be so good at managing getting
stuff done managing organizations
relating to people and for them if they
go into consulting first they're just
gonna get better at their strengths you
know they're gonna get better at batting
right-handed and they're never gonna
learn how to bat left-handed because it
- for years it'd be a nightmare for them
to shift because they were already
remedial and they were immediately in
remedial in that area another triply
remedial and so so what I was said is if
you think you want to run something for
profit not for profit if you're really
incredibly smart aleck side and then
don't go to being a McKenzie first go
work on those weaknesses and learn how
to run stuff because you can always fall
back you're still gonna be smart in four
years you're still gonna be analytical
and you can't miss that growth
opportunity for working on your
weaknesses because you need to have some
of all of that if you want to be a good
general manager CEO similarly if you're
a good team builder and and manager your
task Orion and stuff like project stuff
that's your sweet spot and but God
you've sort of marvel at how some other
people can do a case in half the time
that you do and they get every important
point and you only got two-thirds then I
say get your butt into consulting
because then you work on work on that
and so I think there's it's very much a
situation person specific answer and for
me I needed I needed to be more
strategically aggressive in how I
thought I need to be more conceptual I
needed to do better at coming up with
paradigms that were collectively are
exhaustive and usually exclusive so for
me it was a gift and for me to shift
into management was I go kay I was I was
born to raise that to to play that sport
a lot to learn but that just fits with
my natural athletic orientation okay
he well thank you very much